the city of Dickinson Texas is now under
a mandatory evacuation order now that is
a low-lying suburb just southeast of
Houston it's home to about 20,000 people
it's been ravaged by flooding and police
are telling everyone to get out DeMarco
Morgan is watching the rescue efforts in
Dickinson DeMarco good morning good
morning nor and part of the reason for
that mandatory evacuation is to keep
people from coming back to their
properties you also talked about the
rescues there are still rescues underway
right now as we speak now the water
started to recede yesterday at a very
fast pace but we've already picked up
more than a foot of rain in this area
here so again it is still dangerous you
can still see that most of this area
here is pretty much flooded out law
enforcement officials are telling people
to be very careful with bringing boats
out here because the waters are very
shallow for a rescue so they're pretty
much calling on vehicles that are much
higher off the ground like big trucks
sanitation trucks to come in and
continue helping with the rescues
because you still have people stuck in
their homes stuck in the apartment
complexes and etc but Adam brown he is
one of the guys from Galveston he was
one of the ones who basically came in
and volunteered filled up his truck with
gas and brought his boat his jet skis he
put out his personal cell phone number
on Facebook asking people look if you
need help call me he was flooded with
text messages and he came to the rescue
now again that mandatory evacuation is
underway right now as we speak so don't
return to this area we are expecting
more rain overnight north
all right DeMarco thank you so much